[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: A fruit turnover
is probably your best
bet if you're eating on the go.
It satisfies a sweet
tooth, it's portable,
and it requires no utensils.
The dough, typically
flaky, is folded over,
usually into a
triangle or rectangle,
and the edges are sealed,
trapping the fruit
filling neatly inside.
These all natural blueberry
turnovers may look and taste
like homemade, but believe it or
not, they come frozen in a box.
You just bake them and eat them.
The manufacturer is willing
to reveal the ingredients.
But the critical proportions,
mixing and heating times
are top secret.
Workers begin making the
filling by heating blueberries.
Next, they combine lemon juice
and starch in a container.
Then, add this mixture
to the blueberries.
The starch is
white now, but will
become transparent as it cooks.
They mix some more.
Then add salt. When the starch
is opaque, they add sugar
and mix some more.
As soon as the temperature
of the ingredients
reaches 170 degrees Fahrenheit,
the filling is done.
To make the dough, workers
first pour flour into the mixer.
Then salt. After a
few minutes of mixing,
they add butter, lots of butter.
Once it's well blended,
they add some water.
After a bit more mixing,
the dough is ready.
This type of dough is called
pate au beurre, the French term
for a butter-based
pastry that's extremely
light and flaky due to its
high ratio of fat to flour.
Now, workers weigh
out 12 pound portions
and put them one at a time into
a dough press with a sprinkling
of flour to prevent sticking.
The press compresses
the dough into a 10
by 16 inch block
that's one inch thick.
Then they line up the blocks
on a floured conveyor belt,
joining them together to form
one continuous sheet of dough.
The dough sheet
now enters a press.
Inside, rollers compress
the sheet to about a quarter
of its original thickness.
The next machine layers
the thin dough sheet.
This flower press and layer
process repeats over and over
again until the sheet is
just a tenth of an inch
thick, yet contains 24 layers.
These layers are what
will make the pastry
exceptionally light and flaky.
Trimming wheel's on the
sides make a neat edge.
Diagonally bladed wheels score
the dough with small cuts.
And cutting wheel's
divide the sheet
into five strips, each of which
will become a row of turnovers.
The next station deposits
a line of water droplets
along one edge of each strip.
This creates a line
of sticky dough.
The preparations are all
done and assembly can begin.
First, with precision
spacing, nozzles
squirt one ounce of blueberry
filling per turnover.
Then a device called a
folding plow, because it looks
like a farm plow, lifts
one edge of the dough
and gradually folds it over.
A smooth wheel then presses that
edge down onto the sticky line
on the other edge.
This seals the open
side of the strips.
The culinary choreography
ends with a bang, or rather,
a chop, as a guillotine
descends cutting the strips
into individual turnovers,
and simultaneously
sealing the front and
back ends of each pastry.
The assembled turnovers
now go on a 6-minute ride
through a nitrogen
flash freezing tunnel.
Temperature, minus 183
degrees Fahrenheit.
Under a shower of
sugar crystals,
they exit the tunnel,
frozen, hard as a rock.
Packaged, four to
a box the turnovers
remain frozen until you
bake them in your oven
and serve them up.